bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct matin avec nous pour ce
débat politique berthet france on vient
d'entendre ces parisiens s'exprimer sur
cette question de l'autorité de l'état
hier le figaro a publié un ce rapport du
ministère de l'intérieur qui montre que
sur la période 2013 2018 il y a cette
fois plus de victimes d'agressions
physiques chez les gendarmes et les
policiers que la moyenne des
travailleurs qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire gens mais s'il ya pour commencer
bah écoutez je pense que depuis
maintenant une quarantaine d'années
le grand remplacement qui est à l'oeuvre
par une politique migratoire incontrôlée
et l'abandon de la notion d'assimilation
de des personnes qui arrivent se traduit
par un grand harcèlement un harcèlement
permanent de nos forces de l'ordre dans
certains quartiers un harcèlement des
femmes dans les rues
voilà donc on a effectivement depuis une
quarantaine d'années au pouvoir une une
génération ici d étudiant de mai 68
des crocs de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui les progressistes pour qu il
est interdit d'interdire donc l'autorité
de l'état est elle et elle est battue en
brèche pas seulement évidemment par là
par une peur du gendarme ou du policier
qui n'existe plus dans certains
quartiers
encouragés par des élites qui qui
explique à certains quartiers que ce
sont d'éternels victime et qui ne
peuvent en aucun cas être des coupables
de par leurs origines de par notre
société
et vous avez aussi la peur
la remise en cause de l'autorité à
partir de l'école on voit que ces images
de professeurs qui sont eux qui sont
agressés qui sont acquis au manque de
respect dans les classes etc et dont et
qui sont quasiment jamais défendu par la
hiérarchie
au nom de nos noms du pas de vagues
voilà donc il y a effectivement un état
de droit en france le problème c'est
qu'il est battue en brèche par les pires
ennemis à la fois de l'état et du droit
mais qu'ils sont les meilleurs amis des
gauchos progressistes et des
progressistes le droite et de gauche qui
gouverne
france depuis une quarantaine d'années
et c'est donc ce que nous vivons c'est
une conséquence de cela c'est pas une
génération spontanée comme tend à nous
le faire croire le ps et les
républicains qui gouverne la france
depuis tant d'années c'est la
conséquence de la politique la réponse
de jérôme lambert c'est vrai que les
autres professionnels les plus visés
sont les professions intermédiaires de
la santé du travail social suivi
justement par les professeurs des écoles
les instituteurs et assimilés jérôme
lambert on vous en médias parlent de la
politique menée par par les régimes près
par les gouvernements précédents le
parti socialiste at il une part de
responsabilité dans ce déclin de
l'autorité de l'état
seul et les professions des professions
qui assure le maintien de l'ordre dans
notre pays les gendarmes les policiers
en premier lieu aussi les polices
municipales bien entendu sont confrontés
tous les jours à la violence et parfois
la folie en charente ils interviennent
dans des conflits familiaux dans les
bagarres entre personnes en état
d'ébriété et c'est
donc la réalité d'ailleurs de la plupart
de nos territoires c'est pas la réalité
qui existe aussi dans certaines zones
très difficiles de grandes villes et
pour autant donc effectivement la
violence souvent prendre pas mais la
violence s'est souvent d'ailleurs je ne
vois moi dans mon département elle est
souvent lié à un phénomène par exemple
d'ébriété les gens qui sont ivres s'en
prennent y s'en prennent aux policiers
aux gendarmes
oui oui mais bien entendu mais je sais
quand on parle de cette fois plus de
blessés de personnes agressées dans la
profession dans les professions liées à
la sécurité
je dirais c'est leur métier d'être
confrontés à la violence parfois la
folie vous pouvez sortir des
statistiques aussi sur les accidents
routiers vous verrez qu'il ya beaucoup
plus de personnes qui prennent leur
voiture tous les jours pour leur métier
qui sont victimes de la violence au sein
des accidents routiers
voilà c'est la réserve maintenant qui
donc qui ont des sept fois plus que les
autres dans soit c'est pas tellement
étonnant je ne dis pas que c'est pas
choquant mais c'est pas étonnant ils
sont confrontés encore une fois tous les
jours a défait le même de violences qui
sont le faible de toute la société pas
seulement d'une partie de la société on
voit d'ailleurs pas seulement en france
la pire violence d'après les chiffres
que nous pouvons avoir elle sait pas en
europe c'est pas en france mais c'est
aux états unis dans un bayou dans un
pays certes qui a beaucoup d'états
beaucoup de législation parfois un peu
différente mais dans lesquelles la
réglementation générale est très très
sévère il est tellement couru sont très
sévèrement c'est donc chrome est
confrontée à une vraie difficulté c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui
des jeunes ne font à travers aussi leurs
modes d'éducation
l'allée des images qui peuvent voir dans
les médias
sont confrontés en permanence à la
violence et à mon avis ce sont des
mauvais exemples justement alors je vais
vous montrer des images de ces
agressions la jeune milla qui a déjà été
menacé de mort pour avoir critiqué les
islamistes sur les réseaux sociaux a
publié une nouvelle vidéo où elle dit
être victime d'agressions à caractère
sexiste mais sexuelle regarde
on
parle moi j'aime pas droit j'ai pas
intéressé par vos avances sexuelles on
traite de
alors cassé vous cassez vous aucune
femme
est là elle a porté plainte
l'homme soupçonné enfin on voit qu'il y
en a plusieurs mais en tout cas un homme
soupçonné de l'avoir harcelé a été
interpellé dimanche il est actuellement
en garde à vue jean mais s'il ya ce ce
genre de scène n'est pas n'est pas isolé
en france comment y mettre un terme
non mais c'est à quelques il faut bien
comprendre les ressorts de ce mécanisme
contrairement à ce que j'entendais il ya
un instant de la part de monsieur
lambert qui s'est livré à un exercice de
délégation et de déni qui caractérise sa
formation politique depuis maintenant
plusieurs années il est évident
qu'aujourd'hui une composante majeure de
l'ensauvagement de notre société est lié
à une immigration massive et incontrôlée
c'est un fait je sais que ça fait mal
pour des gens qui ont répété et bellay
pendant quarante ans que l'immigration
est une chance pour la france de voir ce
genre de scène si on fait aujourd'hui
une enquête et qu'on demande à
l'ensemble des femmes harcelées de
décrire le profil de leurs harceleur une
majorité très grande majorité d'entre
elles répondront que les concerts seront
toujours au quasiment toujours le même
profil c'est à dire que ce sont des gens
issus de l'immigration
voilà c'est terrible à dire mais c'est
le réel on peut passer vous voulez pour
tenter de de perméabilité une idéologie
par rapport au réel rester dans un
espèce de deux circuits clos en récitant
les mêmes fadaises ce qui est né a le
don d'énerver les français ce que
propose justement eric zemmour pour en
finir avec ça c'est déjà d'arrêter
immédiatement
l'immigration c'est l'immigration zéro
alors je dis pas qu'il n'ya pas
évidemment il composantes de délinquance
et de violence qui est nationale mais
elle est évidemment sans commune mesure
avec cette violence et cette délinquance
importée donc déjà si on pouvait
empêcher la délinquance et la violence
importée on se donnerait un peu plus de
rien pour régler la violence et la
délinquance nationale je pense qu'il
faut ensuite réduire ou en mettre fin au
droit du sol d'accord mettre fin aux
pompes aspirantes de l'immigration que
sont toutes les prestations sociales et
notre état providence qui est ouvert à
la terre entière parce qu'encore une
fois on si on veut pacifier la société
on ne saurait le faire que par l'arrêt
de l'immigration j'ajoute enfin pour
terminer que vous avez un quart des
prisonniers dans les prisons qui sont
étrangers il faudrait qu'à l'issue de
leur péniche où ils soient expulsés pour
libérer les princes de prison parce
qu'une des raisons aussi de du non
respect de l'autorité de l'état c'est
que la justice même si les peines
prononcées sont très sévères eh bien
elles elles ne sont que peu ou pas
appliquées en raison de l'engorgement
des prisons donc si vous déverrouillez
les places de prison vous allez
fluidifier toute la chaîne pénale
permettre aux juges de condamner à la
prison plus fréquemment passe avec plus
de chance que les personnes qui passent
devant eux soit effectivement embastillé
voilà le programme et laisser des choses
comme ça à vau l'eau traitée comme
monsieur lambert toutes ces choses de
éviter le problème éviter de dire les
problèmes le problème dire que
finalement la violence c'est des petits
chenapans quinon qui n'ont que faire qui
n'ont pas d'idées eux qui l'ont clients
pas de l'idéologie derrière etc où il
n'y a pas de cause macroéconomiques au
phénomène c'est se condamner non
seulement à continuer à le vivre mais à
le voir s'amplifier ces séances passées
depuis maintenant une dizaine d'années
jérôme lambert
l'immigration responsable delà de ces
agressions je sais pas dans quel monde
on vit mais moi en charente dans mon
département rural
les violences faites aux femmes ce sont
des des sommes tout à fait intégré des
français
des gens qui sont pas d'origine
étrangère parce qu'il ya peu personnes
d'origine étrangère et pourtant nous
sommes confrontés aux mêmes violences
cette société violent devient violente
l'individualisme
l'idéologie libérale qui pousse les uns
à agir contre les autres limbes le
manque de solidarité
il ya effectivement une montée de la
violence dans notre pays mais elle est
le propre de tout le monde moi en tout
cas dans mon département je vais vous
dire encore une fois les violences
faites aux femmes sont pas le fait des
gens ils n'iraient pas ce qu'il y'a très
passé les quinze l'idée mais s'attend à
l'inversé il ya beaucoup de montée de la
violence quant à aux attentes à la
prison tout ce qu'il faut faire autour
des prix zone on peut certes améliorer
le nombre de personnes emprisonnées mais
dans votre petit reportage vous aviez
une personne qui disait qu'elle
travaillait dans le domaine de la
réinsertion et elle a eu un mot elle a
dit les prisons abymes en fait il faut
trouver une bonne composition entre la
sanction puis l emprisonnement la mise à
l'écart le fait de que ces personnes
puissent puis nuit avait mais il faut
aussi ce que la prison servent à quelque
chose parce que quand il passe un an
deux ans ou même cinq ans ce qui est
très lent déjà en prison et qu'ils en
sortent pire que quand ils en sont
rentrés et bien la situation ne
s'améliore pas bien entendu la prison a
dit mme comme disait
c'est une preuve les professionnels le
disent moi j'ai été il ya quelques
années dans une mission parlementaire
qui avait pour objet de regarder des
conséquences de la récidive j'avais
conditions de récidive on voyait que
nous on a un très mauvais score en
france comparé à d'autres pays on pense
au canada en son pays de l'europe du
nord donc c'est là dessus aussi qu'il
faut intervenir un seul sur comment
comment empêcher ou comment diminuer les
récidives et c'est pas nécessairement
uniquement en augmentant les plaques des
places de prison ils font surtout en
vendée des politiques de d'insertion de
meilleure insertion on va continuer sur
l'actualité puisque les députés
débattent aujourd'hui du retrait de la
force barkan du mali emmanuel macron a
dit la semaine dernière que cela
prendrait au moins quatre à six mois les
autorités maliennes lui ont aussitôt
répondu regarder au regard de ces
manquements répétés aux accords de
défense le gouvernement invite les
autorités françaises à retirer sans
délai les forces barkan est à kouba du
territoire national sous la supervision
des autorités maliennes gens mais s'il
ya la france qui se retire du mali qui
doit le faire tout de suite c'est ce que
disent les maliens emmanuel macron a dit
non comment comment engager ce ce
retrait selon vous quelle est la
position de la reconquête sur cette
question de l'engagement de barques
anomalies
m'écouter cette déclaration du
gouvernement malien ressemble à un
véritable camouflet sinon une
humiliation infligée à la france qui
rappelons le
reste n'est en déplaise aux
progressistes une grande puissance avec
un statut de membre permanent au conseil
de sécurité
la france qui a déversé des centaines de
millions d'euros pour effectivement
soutenir à bout de bras le mali qui a
perdu quand même faut-il le rappeler 53
de ses soldats en opération et se voir
ainsi traités avec une telle
pantalonnade je serai manuel macron
franchement j'aurai un peu honte voilà
il n'est pas possible plus il aurait
fallu se retirer avant ben je pense
qu'il aurait fallu se retire avant
laisser éventuellement quelques forces
spéciales sur place pour
cibler la poursuite des terroristes mais
lorsque la france est entré dans une
logique de state building comme on dit
en français c'est à dire de cons
reconstruction de l'état malien toutes
ces opérations de state building par le
passé se sont révélé être un échec et
emmanuel macron de même que françois
hollande d'ailleurs ne pouvait l'ignorer
c'est ce que les américains ont essayé
de faire en irak avec le succès qu'on
connaît ou même encore plus récemment en
libye là également avec le succès qu'on
connaît donc il fallait s'il voulait se
retirer garder des pour spécial sur
place pour opérer un craquage cibler des
djihadistes et ça certainement pas s'y
éterniser certainement pas essayer de
construire une société au mali c'est aux
maliens de construire leur propre
société par ailleurs je m'étonne que
avec dans ces conditions alors même que
le mali est capable de dire un pays qui
les a sauvés du jihadisme en gros
emparez-vous
nous en france on a des scrupules de
gazelle a expulsé des dizaines de
milliers de maliens jeunes pour la
plupart arrivé en france pour fuir la
guerre pendant que la france envoyer ces
jeunes soldats eux pour combattre et
mourir donc il est maintenant temps
maintenant que le mali à un gouvernement
et que ce gouvernement est tellement
fort qu'il est capable de virer la
france eh bien il est bien temps de
renvoyer chez eux à tous les maliens
nous avons en france et que nous avons
accueillis au nom de la guerre y régnait
dans ce pays voilà
tous les grands états et même les petits
états qui ont une dignité et bien
agissent dans le concert des nations il
n'y a qu'en france où nous avons des
élites qui sont dénationaliser et qui
préfèrent voir l'intérêt du monde
l'intérêt de l'afrique plutôt que
l'intérêt national français qu'ils
apparentent à du fascisme jérôme lambert
vous êtes député les députés vont
débattre de cette question à l'assemblée
aujourd'hui sur quoi peuvent porter les
débats un débat réclamé de longue date
qu'il aurait dû avoir lieu bien avant ce
débat selon vous
c'est que il est toujours facile de
donner des leçons après coup il aurait
fallu nous aurions dû ça fait longtemps
fin mai enfin les la situation
d'aujourd'hui et doit être appréhendée
au regard de ce qui s'est passé encore
une fois assez récemment et ce qui s'est
passé récemment c'est que le mali est
tombé sous une forme de dictature je
rappelle que l'huile de coude et un
espace de même pas un an au mali et que
ce soit le premier ou le deuxième
d'ailleurs le gouvernement malien n'est
pas un gouvernement légitime des pins
gouvernement démocratique c'est un
gouvernement d'ailleurs qui n'est pas
reconnu par tous ses voisins aucun aucun
gouvernement aucun pays voisin du mali
et même dans le monde ne reconnaît une
quelconque légitimité à la dictature du
mali alors la france est là et là bas la
france est venue dans un tout autre
contexte appelé par un gouvernement
légitime gouvernement démocratique et le
tout mais maintenant effectivement de
sortir de ce guêpier parce que le mali
est devenu un véritable guêpier mais
c'est lié pas certain d'ailleurs au bout
de quelques années de neuf ans de
présence française que le mali soit
sauvée du terrorisme en tout cas il n'a
pas été sauvé le un putsch militaire
et le terrorisme c'est un fait c'est ans
aujourd'hui
qui entoure le mali il s'est notamment
le terrorisme donc l'action de la france
qu'il faut saluer parce que lui beaucoup
de sacrifices effectivement mais
l'action de la france n'a pas été
particulièrement bénéfique on a sauvé le
gouvernement malien lors de notre
intervention quand françois hollande a
décidé de l'intervention mais après coup
on s'est installé dans une zone où le
terrorisme n'a fait que des produits de
soins nous faut tirer des leçons il nous
reste peu de temps pour est complexe à
cette dernière question hasard du
calendrier ou pas en tout cas jeudi
dernier c'est le jour où eric zemmour a
proposé sa vision pour la défense il
veut une hausse du budget de 29
milliards d'euros en 2030 écouter eric
zemmour
notre armée et échantillonneur avec à
peine 5 alain
lacunaire et taillé au plus juste comme
un corps à corps expéditionnaire meutre
armées ne disposent pas de la masse
nécessaire pour durer dans un conflit de
haute intensité tant sur le plan humain
que sur le plan matériel il ya de fortes
ambitions eric zemmour il veut à
construire un porte avions
supplémentaires avoir deux porte avions
300 avions de chasse d'ici à 2040
jean-mi cias et c'est un peu ambitieux
comme comme projet pour l'armée non
c'est ambitieux pour la remise tant
mieux pour la france surtout parce que
vous savez la question toujours c'est de
dire que tu dis moi quelle vision tu as
de la france des 10 quelle politique de
défense tu auras c'est sûr que dans une
france qui est qui et pour depuis des
années maintenant devenu le petit
télégraphiste de washington que qu'on a
intégré le commandement intégré de
l'otan et bien la vision de la défense a
été a été celle d'une vision
lilliputienne c'est à dire peu
ambitieuse c'est aussi ça a été aussi la
défense qui a subi le plus de coupes
budgétaires parce que vous savez quand
on veut faire des économies au sein de
l'état c'est toujours dans la défense
donc on sait qu'elle va de quel va être
le bon élève des ministères qui s'adapte
et pourtant je veux dire c'est que les
fans du ctia sous le gouvernement
d'emmanuel macro mais pas un pape a
suffisamment madame et sans aucune
logique d'ensemble je pense que de ce
que propose eric zemmour est ambitieux
parce qu'ils offrent une logique
d'ensemble ils couplent une politique de
défense ambitieuse d'équipements et de
stratégie avec une politique
diplomatique qui renoue avec la grandeur
de la france dans le monde et qui renoue
surtout avec la souveraineté et
l'indépendance il faut sortir du
commandement intégré de l'otan et
reconstruire une défense française
indépendante comme l'avait voulu le
général de gaulle aujourd'hui nous
sommes en bon c'est dans des alliances
suranné qui n'ont plus lieu d'être comme
celle de l'otan qui nous vaut des
difficultés avec des pays avec lesquels
normalement nous aurions nous aurions dû
avoir des relations normales c'est à
dire la russie nous nous trouvons
embringué dans l'otan et dans le conflit
craignant de par notre appartenance à
l'otan alors que nous n'avons rien à y
faire il faut effectivement autres
renouer avec l'indépendance de la france
et redonner à nos armes et les moyens de
satin dépendants et rejouer
sans armée pardonnez moi j'en mets
sillage beaucoup parce qu'il nous reste
vraiment 30 secondes je voudrais que
jérôme lambert répondent à cet avenir de
la défense française
il est certain que pays pour assurer son
indépendance
la diplomatie aussi
besoin d'une force militaire important
que personne ne le conteste après on
peut dire il faut toujours plus fort
toujours plus la france déjà consacre
beaucoup de moyens à sa défense
peut-être moins en proportion que les
états unis qui sont champions du monde
mais tiers enfin beaucoup plus que la
plupart de nos voisins donc il faut
continuer mais pour répondre monsieur
zemmour la france n'a pas 100 pièces
d'artillerie la france j'aime de
vérifier la france en a 300 sans compter
les pièces d'artillerie antiaérienne il
a parlé il après un quart d'heure de nom
elle comporte le nombre peut considérer
que 300 sait pas encore à ce dollars
ferry
donc
voilà il se dit beaucoup de choses si on
dit beaucoup d'exagération dans une
campagne électorale
c'est parfois bien malheureux il faut
ces questions sont sérieuses il faut les
traiter sérieusement merci beaucoup à
tous les deux on en reverra plus en
détails en tout cas merci d'avoir
participé à ce débat ce matin en direct
dans la matinale d'ayrté france